In 2014, some British YouTube stars were called
out by the British advertising regulators
for not properly declaring sponsored content.
They mentioned the sponsorship in the description,
they said "thanks to the company for making
this possible" at the end:
it wasn't like they were trying to hide it,
but it wasn't enough.
It had to be clear before you clicked on the
video, that it was an advert.
In a world so saturated with advertising:
why was that a problem?
Well, British media has some of the strongest
product placement laws in the world.
Most of the rest of the planet, though?
They don't really care. And the reason,
as with so many things, goes back to history.
Back in the first years of television,
all Britain had was the BBC from Alexandra
Palace. Paid for not by advertising,
but by a yearly tax on anyone who owned a
television. And that's still true.
So advertising wasn't, and isn't,
allowed on the BBC. In the United States,
though,
they had commercial television right from
the start -- and a -- whaa! --
a show's host would regularly interrupt their
patter
to give a personal endorsement down the camera
for a better brand of umbrella(!)
"Unless you're smoking L&Ms, all you can do
is imagine how good they taste."
But in the UK, that sort of thing was seen
as horribly tacky.
When commercial TV launched here,
admags, weird half-soap-opera,
half-infomercials, existed for a few years,
but it just wasn't the British way of doing
things, darling(!)
So in the 60s, strict rules were laid down:
advertising and
content must never collide. No product placement,
at all.
Which led to some things that Americans would
find very strange:
our version of the Price is Right,
for example, couldn't mention brand names.
You might win a brand new car,
but the announcer would never say what make
of car it was.
"A 1.3 hatchback!"
Teleshopping and infomercials existed, and
still do,
but they had to be clearly flagged,
on screen with a title, saying what they were.
Were there dodgy dealings going on behind
the scenes?
Did some producers get backhanders for making
sure
that the heroes of their drama used a certain
type of computer?
Almost certainly. But you wouldn't see, for
example,
those heroes stopping for lunch at one particular
chain restaurant
and emphasising how good the food was.
"This Subway sandwich? So ono."
You know how the American Idol judges all
had those big branded cups in front of them?
They had to be blurred out when that series
was shown over here.
Other product placements, like those in movies,
or sports broadcasts coming from sponsored
arenas, were deemed acceptable,
but the regulators generally took a hard line
on entertainment made here in Britain.
That's what the folks who grew up in Britain
are used to.
That's what the people making the decisions
see as the standard for the country's television.
So as you might imagine,
our advertising rules in general are a bit
more restrictive too.
There is a thing called the Advertising Standards
Authority who write the Advertising Codes.
Now, the codes are technically voluntary,
but in practice it's as good as the law.
Because few companies want the bad publicity
that'll come from breaking it,
no TV channels or newspapers will dare to
run ads that break the Codes,
and ad agencies, the people who make the commercials,
don't want to get in trouble either.
Because the alternative is the government
starts setting the rules
instead of the advertising industry itself,
and they'll make breaking the Code an actual
criminal offence
rather than just something that gets your
advert pulled.
Now, the rules have been relaxed recently.
Provided it's flagged up with a tiny symbol
at the start of the show,
some commercial TV can now include product
placements.
But for advertisers used to the permissiveness
of America,
modern-day British TV is still a shock:
adverts can't editorially affect the show,
and
they can't talk about how good the product
is. Also,
you can't product-place food that's high in
sugar, fat or salt,
and there's absolutely no product placement
at all within children's programs.
The Advertising Standards Authority lives
in the building behind me,
and the Code they write has hundreds of pages
of rules governing all sorts of ads.
But there are two very important sections
for what we're talking about,
and given the rules I mentioned earlier,
they probably won't surprise you.
Number 1: no matter where they are,
adverts must be clearly identifiable as adverts.
And number 2: you can't advertise unhealthy
food to children.
So you might see why the regulators got a
bit annoyed at vloggers with teen audiences
selling cookies in the middle of their regular
videos without any warning.
Now, to be fair:
the regulators hadn't actually produced any
help or advice for the industry on this
back then, a year and a half ago as I record
this.
They were caught on the back foot.
And the vloggers themselves weren't really
expected to know this,
it was the ad agency's job -- the client that
hired them --
to check that they were compliant.
And the agencies either got carried away at
what seemed like this new, unregulated world,
or they were American and didn't know or care
about it.
British TV is still seen, at least by people
in Britain, as a gold standard.
We don't do those horrible product placements.
Not on television, anyway. As for YouTube,
and the rest of the internet: well,
the rules are still being written.
All of which is a long-winded way of saying
that
my videos are open for product placement now,
if you're a company: do get in touch!
[Translating this video? Add your name here if you'd like credit!]